do you think there's an accident waiting
to happen here it depends what an
accident is in terms of definition but I
would say this we have had very heavy
capital flight over the last eight nine
months coming out of China and if I had
to bet on someone the local knowledge or
some economy somewhere in the world
talking of China and how great it is I
would bet on the locals who are shifting
money out of China at the record level
at the present time secondly the growth
figures that the government are
publishing do not match the reality say
exports are down imports are down
industrial production is down car sales
were down maybe they stabilized for a
while but a lot of indicators are very
negative Railway freight traffic is down
17 percent year-on-year do you want to
tell me that the economy is growing at
six point nine percent it doesn't rhyme
but is it fair to say the economy is
barely growing at all or is it just not
growing at the rate and speed in which
we've grown accustomed to because
there's a big difference I think many
people don't understand that China has a
population twice as large as the US and
Europe combined it's not just a country
it's an entire empire and you can have
growth in some sectors of the economy I
have no doubt that some service sectors
are growing but other very important
sectors like industrial production isn't
growing at the present time and the way
the US had sometimes a recession in
California like in the early 1990s and
other states were growing you can have
in China some provinces growing and
others contracting and so
to measure economic growth in a country
this large with that many people is very
difficult but say the evidence shows
that it's nowhere growing at the same
pace it was growing say between 2000 and
2007 and what we have had in China and
this investor should realize is a credit
bubble of epic proportions I have a red
economic history I've never seen credit
as a percent of the economy growing as
fast as in China in the last 7 years